we won't talk about some end games in an
earlier class if you were here but today
with a little bit more work on the end
games in the first position I have for
you here is if you look at the position
it's white white is down upon and but he
can make a draw here and the way it
works is he can make a draw here if he
knows how to do a distant opposition so
we talk about the normal opposition
diagonal opposition we practice today
and now we're going to talk about the
distant opposition when there is a
distance actually between your king and
blocking and waiking so I want to give
you a little bit time to think maybe a
minute or two and ask you then what is
the correct move here
to get that distant opposition because
remember should be odd number of squares
between each King and there should be
some distance here because unfortunately
if we come if we come here to do the
regular opposition it's not gonna work
because he goes King Ditu and you go
King f2 and he goes King to d3 and
suddenly he cannot do much he cannot go
here and if the king moves king g3 and
King g2 if you go King g4 he will get
behind upon and this will be already
losing because you have to move the king
and if you move the King he will take
the pawn and just promote upon into a
queen and if you go here kingi to if the
king goes back he takes the pawn and if
he goes here he will accomplish the same
idea by going behind the pawn again and
King to g4 and King to f2 and this way
now he will push the white king away and
pick up the pawn on f3
and once he wins the pawn it would be
quite easy he will just push the pawn
down the line and get a new queen
so that's why in this position we cannot
play the move King f1 okay so but what
can we do here so we can get that
distant opposition here what do you
think is the right move here for that
yes King h1 correct we go King h1 and
now we have some distance right we have
a distance here they're three different
squares now there's some space and
that's the distant distant opposition
okay now let's see now how this works
he's gonna come forward and now what do
you do
don't rush you gotta keep that distant
opposition you got it now
if you were king jutsu you lose the
opposition because he will just go King
to ito he will get the opposition okay
King to h2 King to d3
now yes absolutely
even though there is a point in between
but still you keep that opposition okay
now he goes here continue again there
absolutely
now he goes back yes are you sure your
palm
I will take your pawn if you go away
from this pond I will take it
absolutely now I go here the test yeah
now this is we started actually yes and
now I'm gonna try something else so we
have ready we repeat it once now he's
gonna play g4 sacrificing a pawn
but if you play the wrong move here
you're gonna lose so now he's giving you
the pawn he says okay you can have this
pawn do we want to take it though
question is
very good and most importantly he was
gonna promote the pawn into a queen with
the check okay so he pushes you go here
he pushes you go here push
you're almost there you know you're
almost there but not quite promote sin
to queen size check and then he goes
down and stops you from clinic and it
wins okay so that's why when he plays g4
we cannot take we cannot take care if we
take we're gonna lose so but we have a
good move here what is the good move
here yes very good King to Jeter now
coming closer and protecting our upon if
he now exchanges we take of course and
after we take we're going to come up
here on a four and we're gonna pick up
that pawn only five okay King against
King no material left yes that's why
yeah that's why he's probably not gonna
do that he's gonna go here and now now
what do we do now
yes you could go king f2 but then then
he actually takes us take and he goes
here and he's gonna push push and he's
gonna promote okay okay so that's why
now now he can actually push the pawn
down and and gonna be able to win so but
position has changed a little bit how
the king is no longer on the back rank
okay the king is no longer on the back
rank so that means he's not going to be
able to promote the pawn with a check so
maybe it's time to begin the race yeah
because we no longer we know long it's
no longer gonna Queen yes f takes e4
correct
well it's same idea of we just did it
takes king g3 he takes now you have to
take right and then it goes King well if
you take G goes here now if you could
get your king only four yes you could
get a drop but here you're not gonna be
able to get there okay and then you just
push
so what is the correct move now okay
what is the correct move here let's
think we're King is already yes if they
see four okay now it's a race here
because one two three four one two three
four but the difference is he's not
going to be able to check anymore
because your King moved from the back
rank so he push pushes the push
so both Clare's gonna be able to Queen
so what place Queen but it's just got to
be a draw because there's there is no
way black can win the Queen here okay
so that's why it's a draw
okay so this is the only way actually in
this position is a move that you play
here the move king h1 it's a it's not a
it's not a natural move here it's a bit
odd move here you play you kind of move
the King further away but that's the
only way for you to accomplish that
opposition to move that away okay let's
try to look at this position let's try
to understand what's what's happening
now okay it's white to play in this
position and you need to win this win
this game and for a moment it looks like
shouldn't be that difficult I mean we
have a rook the knight is hanging we can
just take the knight and then we wrap
the rook can we take the knight is that
a good idea
why why it's not a good idea yes go
ahead
because it will be still mate right so
you take the night see this happens a
lot players think oh it's a free piece
they take and then wait a minute
still mate so this makes the task
difficult you have a question well black
is going this way white is going this
way remember the way you determine who
is going which way is always looking at
the letters okay if it's 1 & 2 white is
going that way
7 & 8 black is going the other way okay
so so don't rush okay don't rush we had
some other examples today when Clair's
rushed to make a move and suddenly it
was still mate you saw that so we have
to make sure we don't still mate in a
winning position but on the other hand
it looks like what to do we have to move
the rook but if we move the rook away he
takes our last part and this is a draw
theoretical draw because lon rook and
King versus the king and night it's a
draw and black still has a pawn here
it's not going to play a big role this
pawn but it's basically draw anyway okay
so if you move your route he's gonna
take your pot and it's gonna be a draw
okay so that's why you don't want to do
that that's a very difficult move here
very difficult move that you need to
find here and then you're going to be
able to get the winning position yes but
then I also want to take your rook I'm
not only threatening here
I'm also threatening to take your rook
no we want to win for white what draw
its draw it's quite easy you can just
take the night and it's still made so
you can get a draw that way too but we
want to win and then you're going to
take here and he's gonna sacrifice his
night and then you have to agree to draw
you think you know this one this is
quite advanced quite advanced position
here okay let's go try a haruka a check
very interesting when you do this move
you have to calculate yeah because you
cannot just make this move you have to
calculate the consequences what's gonna
happen in the King and pawn and game
after we do this okay so now it says
rook a check first let's take a look
what's gonna happen if I take with a
knight
because looks like I can do that it's
okay it's okay but you still got the
first move okay you got the correct idea
so now Knight takes rook and for a
moment it looks like we're down a whole
night how we can even possibly think
about winning here but it's a very
concrete position now what can you do
here his King is boxed in it's kind of
trapped in that corner right so what can
we do to make him more so he cannot go
anywhere to take away some more squares
from him more hands yeah yes wait King
c8 excellent job King c8 correct now ah
very good night is trapped king is
trapped polish trapped
so he has only one legal move here so if
let's say just to show you if we had
let's say if we add if we had this here
and it's black to play what is this
still mate always remember about still
mates here because you can win and draw
many games you know if you know what is
the seal still mate huh well he did
already
well kink kink he took wooden Knight
okay now but now he has only one more
right he goes here capture of course now
he goes here and now we capture and he
has the opposition but now what is the
correct square remember in a previous
lecture we got this position we are
different order but how we get here how
we play the right move now to make sure
that no steel mates will happen in this
game no steel mates kink a6 very good
leave the door open for the King so he
can go away from there okay you want him
to go away now if he goes here you
simply go King a7 and you push push and
you Quinn okay so he will play here King
to a eight and now yes
absolutely
push when you have a passport you want
to push of course you have to calculate
but now main idea is to push yes palm b7
King c7 and now okay seven and you
promote upon into a queen
okay okay and you promote into a queen
okay I mean you Queen and then you will
win okay so that's one way how the game
can develop now there is another very
important detail here now if he takes
with the king it leads to a same
position we just take the knight he will
come forward we will go here goes here
and same exact position we're taking a
six and we win
but question is now what's gonna happen
if I am not taking your rook if I see
that I'm gonna lose if I take and I
decided to go King to be seven not
taking it there's only one move can help
you to win this if we don't play this
move you're not gonna be able to win
this what is the move here correct
excellent job rook to a7 check you
continuously sacrifice that rock now for
the second move you want to get that to
that King and pawn endgame okay he has
to take now no choice it's not a still
man yeah he's got a square here oh it's
going this way the pond it's going this
way remember seven eight going this way
down one to go in this way okay so I
take if I go here again if this square
was taken by some other piece they will
be still made but it's not
so he will just take and king take c7
and we reach the same position okay okay
so that's how you win this position it
looks in the beginning of looks quite
easy you know the night is hanging we
have extra look but the only way we can
win here we have to play okay and we
have to find a mover okay seven two
moves in a row we have to sacrifice our
look to win it check here then we go
check okay okay very good
next position now for you okay
anybody familiar with this position this
is a very famous position you might have
seen this in some books and but okay you
need to find a way to win here for white
and you want to do that in only two
moves if you do it in three moves not
good
white to play checkmate in two
white to play checkmate you think about
it a little bit it's a very nice first
move after you find the first move the
rest will be easier because black
doesn't have too many moves here okay
let's see we have a couple of hands here
you sure okay go ahead Luke 287 but here
he takes aha but what do you what do you
get now if it takes you I know but it's
already 2 moves but not checkmate not
quite not quite close but then he can
push actually so you came close but that
bishop is very now came close but the
bishop is there and the bishop is doing
a good job ok now see the King is sort
of in the Box here if we can find a way
to check him without losing that piece
or a pawn it will be a maid but it takes
a very special move here to accomplish
that yes
rook a6
excellent move now there are two options
here Sh take take the rook or move the
bishop if he takes because he doesn't
have any other moves he cannot move the
pawn and he cannot move the King so he
can only do that move the bishop or take
so if he takes now what do you do yes
very nice
checkmate see this box thing cannot go
anywhere and if he moves the bishop
anywhere here he is no longer protecting
can check media how Luke takes a seven
because he's no longer protecting it you
just go rook takes a seven and it's
gonna be a checkmate
okay so you go route k-6
if the bishop moves you go okay seven
okay so this is a very famous position I
want you to memorize this okay because
you will come across this position in
some other books as well that's the only
ways to go here to be able to win
quickly this position is looks like it's
going to be a draw because equal amount
of material on the board on top of that
opposite color bishops opposite call a
bishop means it's if it's equal material
it's very unlikely one of the sides
gonna win yeah without the pawns in here
the problem is only one pawns left on
the board off is a color bishop so it's
look so draw Ashish but the only thing
we have is just the bishop here is plays
badly here on b8 Bishop is placed badly
here on b8 so the first move is so his
King doesn't escape now what do we do
the first move yes correct
Bishop C to check not allowing to come
in not allowing Y to come in here and
other squares are taken so that's one
let's keep going next move here further
we got a further pushing back here how
are we gonna push him back to that
square here yes
one or two think we want to push him
back right if you don't we don't check
him he's not gonna go back so we need
before correct to continue now it's not
about just check check check
now we need a move that will control a
very important square that he's trying
to escape to and if he goes there he's
gonna be able to hold this so you want
to control that important square with
one of your pieces pieces to be able to
stop him from going there so what is the
idea here to control that square
close close but better see black will be
happy to even sacrifice his pawn perfect
blocking the pawn blocking that bishop
if that bishop comes out and you cannot
checkmate it's gonna be a draw so you
got to keep that bishop blocked if
bishop comes out somehow it's going to
be a draw the question is now what about
if you place this move looks like he can
come out right but if he does that do
you see it everybody should see it now
everybody looking everybody I'm gonna
give you a little time here everybody
should be looking and raised because
it's right there now mate in one good
many hands you have it okay let's see I
think you know it but let's see okay
correct Bishop d3 checkmate yes not to
b5 if you go to b5 he escapes you go to
b5 he keeps not gonna work okay so
that's why he cannot play here that's
why he cannot play Bishop to e7 now he
goes back here King to a7 now we need to
control now control the square so he
cannot come here how can we control it
so he cannot bring the King here again
which move we need to play here very
important move there are a few ways to
do it but what's the best way to control
here yes
that's a fine move you can do that what
is the other option you have I like a
little better okay little better
aha this is better you see why little
later now how many moles he has does he
have many moves here's one legal move he
has and that's good when you control all
the squares and opponent has it's good
it's good now he goes here now we have
his King where we want him to be
we cannot checkmate immediately it's
gonna take a little time checkmate in
four from now let's see who can find it
checkmate in four I have to make sure he
cannot escape yeah so checkmate in four
here improve your pieces now which piece
we can improve here let's look at that
way instead of just looking for the mid
let's look for improving the pieces when
we do that then we can find more ideas
yes that's our idea but not right away
improve one of your pieces it's not very
active that piece here improve first and
keep that v6 idea in mind because you're
gonna use that just two moves not right
now correct Bishop a4 centralizing when
you put a piece on a square like that
that's called centralizing your pieces
okay
centralization it's a very important
idea to remember two legal moves he can
play right he's gonna go here because if
he goes here this legal move leads into
how okay good
very good so he's gonna go here and now
now we have we have a good position now
we need a way think move here we want to
have the same position like this but
wait waiting move here because after
that waiting move he will have to go
back and that's where we want him to be
so another thing that for you to learn
today is just remember the waiting move
idea the waiting move idea that we use
in end games yes not quite that changes
things and remember you gotta keep it
locked where you kick see if I push c6
and it's freedom freedom for my bishop
not still mate it's gonna be freedom and
then draw if you let this bishop come
out even if he loses the pawn it's gonna
be a draw so you kind of have to keep
him in that box okay pitch pitch run or
we should be five yeah anywhere on this
diagonal let's do it this way keep it
closer yeah keep it closer more
consolidation when they're protecting
each other we should be fine [ __ ] page
one is fine - how many moves he has now
one right one move he goes here and now
now we are ready now we are ready to
play which move close but then you can
come up or he can push the pot you give
him some options you're close here
absolutely be six now - legal moves
again if he goes here now time to
checkmate checkmate and if he takes here
now what do we do everybody see it now
right the move take it King takes b6
checkmate see from my equal looking
position now opposite color we reach the
final position this should be your final
position where we capture music and say
checkmate okay okay let's take a look at
this position since we did one opposite
color I want to show you another one
with that sort of staying on that team
of opposite color bishops
when you have a light square bishop here
is dark that's opposite color bishop
it's very very dry okay and you'll see
another example here white is up to
healthy pounds here
and in other end games there should be a
guaranteed win if it's Knights rooks
Queen bishops same I mean bishop same
color this is a guarantee win but with
opposite color bishop it's a draw and I
will show you how to make a draw in this
position okay
black will draw this yes so you want to
try the move or you have a question
right
well white can only win this if he
starts pushing his pawns obviously right
if you don't push you're a pawn you're
not gonna win it so he pushes and now
very important moment here he wants to
give you a check and you cannot allow
that to happen okay if you know this
rule how to defend you will draw this
against any player doesn't matter how
strong your opponent is there are no
tricks that your opponent can do in this
position to win even if you play a very
very strong opponent if you know how to
get the right setup with your king and a
bishop you will hold this okay and now
you play the move Bishop to f6 very
important you when opponent has passed
pawns you don't want to defend you don't
want to protect it from the back from
the side that's this is all these ideas
will fail and you will lose the only way
you can hold the position like this if
you attack him from the front okay you
attack him from the front that's the
only way for you to win this and now
you're gonna attack on d4 you go Bishop
f6 but it looks like wait a minute what
about a5 he can just fork here he goes
a5 forking you and winning your Bishop
but if he does that what do you do to
simplify this position what will you do
here yes
you will sacrifice your bishop for a
pond he will take back King 2x back and
you reach this position which I
mentioned today if you have a king and a
minor piece no pants no other pieces
versus a king you cannot win you will
need another pan or a piece to help your
bishop to win here or a knight okay so
you cannot just win with one piece you
need more help and then you can you can
you can win this but here it's a draw
now and let's take a look and see maybe
he will realize that wait if I push a 5
he's going to sacrifice the bishop and
let's say he please d5 but after he
plays d5 immediately it will be a draw
because you will put your bishop here
and what we call this in chess a
position like this where you have what
we call this this is called blockade ok
blockade you've heard of it before
blockade yeah so the pants are blockaded
here he cannot go anywhere he cannot
push this one
King is blocking here and here with the
opposite color bishops he cannot make
any progress because there is no way for
him to push your king or a bishop away
remove the blockade no way for him to do
that so that's why he cannot do anything
so it's gonna be a